yeah you got to be like yo this dude in
the blue shirt is super trash like he's
a magician not a chessler all right here
we go
look at that chess kid subtle branding
sticker on the table
I forgot Danny play this against me and
he won so I'm yeah you're in good hands
yep
I think it was an accident I think I
think I blacked out for those first two
games
[Music]
I'm really scared because you he's
moving with such confidence he doesn't
seem concerned whatsoever it's like it's
like really concerned it's extremely
concerning I don't understand
um this is secret from
your prep my prep actually
I think yeah this is actually true
or maybe I just figured it out or maybe
this is not my friend actually they're
like
um
so I have an option to take that gun you
know
um
wait till it is this legit prep I have a
suggestion Tony why don't you take none
of my buns I just take none of them just
not just don't take any of my pots okay
I won't take any of it okay deals a deal
wow this is actually crazy about this
position no actually yes yeah it is
like actually
okay
I mean this bread is praying off
wait a second
wait a minute yeah this was what I was
fearing when I actually were playing
this a little too focused here for me I
was supposed to be like more Goofy
supposed to
I watched the video of you today
before I was coming here I'm really
sorry and it was about a Magnus
destroying everybody right were you
inspired yeah I was inspired and he
hanged the pawn or not hanged he
sacrificed the wanted to open it first
game
um and he sacrificed the pawn to have
major counter play okay and I'm inspired
by this so I'm doing exactly what he did
because you're giving me way more than
am I mated yes you are
really yes you are oh wait a second oh
my God
yes I think I'm missing my wallet
it's not a good thing everybody
we're gonna be one of those like epic
like oh my gosh
that was so cool that was just like this
whole time I was like my king is safe
foreign
[Laughter]
again I'll jump back in all right
um
look at that
I think Tanya's just trying to avoid all
my nonsense yeah I just don't want any
like okay I'm gonna go eat this that's a
really good move because I can't do this
now
um all right
[Music]
wow now you're playing the bad openings
Tony I know I actually used to play this
when I was 1500 yeah I gained a thousand
points more
[Music]
it's a bad opening
no no his but you're doing you're doing
great Tony make it look good oh
okay
wow okay it's a very edgy way of playing
um would say it's explosive
who would say that I don't know who
would say it's disgusting
all right sometimes jokes you can get
away with online don't work in person it
just doesn't say it louder yeah that's
just like some people's you know some
people are Comedians and their whole
brand is just being super loud like you
just got to be like super confidently
and then when you say it one more time
it's not funny anymore yes that's true
um never overuse a joke it's like for
example why did the old grandma fell
fall in love yeah I'm scared no she
couldn't see that well
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my God oh my God oh no that would
have been so good oh no that would have
been so good that was like my whole idea
but now you just saw it and now it's
almost stabilized the ship in chapter
five
this is crazy
chess in the park with Johnny oh uh oh
we're in trouble yeah yeah I call him
yeah yeah every time I hear that noise I
think grab the camera and run
I'm actually not kidding that's what
goes don't let them take the cameras
they're the most important thing content
yes
you guys don't know this but the loser
has to get a chest kid tattoo after the
game Sorry I want to be the loser now I
see I'll take it he said he's gonna do
it for fun so I'll take it I want to see
it this is I remember I got some
temporary tattoos back in the day
[Music]
some people just recognize you love me
but kept walking they were Starstruck
and also slightly blinded by your shirt
yeah it was probably just that one
they thought you were an addiction did
you hear about that Tony or did you just
say that no he he just he just straight
up called did you just straight up call
him a magician yeah I did we gotta get
down
thank you
can you think about it for 45 more
seconds oh my God
I will exactly do that
um
I guess I shouldn't have reminded him he
has notified
it would have been much better for me
not to remind Tony that he has no time
something very scary is about to happen
it's Brewing up for someone here I don't
know what but
okay okay hmm
72 seconds
it's crazy I'm a little more nervous
about your position than you are Levy
let's go oh no I'm I'm now I'm nervous
all right I would um that's a difficult
question
that pawn was not always hanging
that's crazy a few moments ago
oh my God oh my God
oh that's actually crazy oh my God
how did that happen wow oh my god oh
that's crazy
wait what he's all in I think we play
Bishop six first oh Bishop F6 just one
Bishop six
did you find that I'm like I'm like no I
don't know I made a mistake it happens
wow okay now that that was beautiful
that was okay um go ahead here we go I
want to do Scandinavian again let's see
if we can rinse and repeat that first
one okay no
[Music]
does it work or not what I don't think
it works honey what are you doing
yeah like any time you move I'm like he
understands the content I feel like it
works I feel like it doesn't I don't
even know what time I don't even know
what the idea of that move is I'ma just
I don't what all right just show me
um I don't know if it's gonna work
oh
wait that is not what I thought you were
gonna do oh yeah I was gonna take on the
F7 yeah but
but no no way I think Tony's reaching on
this one I think he's out of I think
he's reaching a little bit
oh my goodness what they ain't no way
stop it Tommy what is this tiny your
coaches are gonna watch this video and
be like why are you developing pieces
like that I mean look at it it's just
it's literally uh what do they call it
what do they call it what do they call
it I don't know what do they call it
what do they call it I said a sentence
didn't finish it um what do they call it
wow
[Music]
oh
I thought it was like more than that you
you made me very scared for a second
what's up puppy hello
oh my gosh hi is that a horse our dog is
like this big I've never seen um
Benjamin yes I remember didn't he is it
better
Benji area the scariest thing about
playing Tawny is not that he's probably
gonna be a grand Masters like he plays
so casually you just don't understand
like where it's coming from you're like
why is he so relaxed like isn't this a
stressful position like why is he not
thinking and he's just like playing fast
like yeah whatever like I'll beat you
anyway you're terrible that's just what
I imagined going through explain exactly
what I'm doing right now Yes mine is the
beating me part no it's it's we're far
from there but but I think this one got
a little wait a minute I feel like I
guess wait a minute I know I'm waiting
yeah but I think I just have a good
position though unless I'm missing a
tactic you're correct oh oh he laughs in
the face
that's a night right there more of a
unicorn
oh my queen is hanging oh yeah that's
probably well luckily I don't lose right
away it's actually not that I was gonna
say I've given you the exchange tax
credit for a minute now it's it's all
part of the plan I just you see how
confidently I played it yeah everybody
was confused including me
but what's so scary
but you literally just plundered The
Exchange and you're just winning here
yeah I'm pretty sure this is like not
even worse for black I have to go here
it's not I mean
um what do I do I need that sweet hatman
man I'll get one of those
fun Master Mike doesn't give me that
kind of custom swag
camera
oh wow Levy I'm not gonna lie I'm I'm
just I'm proud of you I'm not impressed
but I'm proud I'm proud to be proud yep
is that a good thing or a bad thing it's
a great thing so it's in the middle I
can't be impressed because the grade is
on top so never mind because I
absolutely hung my queen yeah like in
one move no questions asked
it's okay it's it's it's never over
oh my God this position is over
mm-hmm
I made it almost to come back hold on
wait yes one second
and now he's zero I made it come back
you did you guys look at this position
okay okay I'll take this one no way you
don't get two moves okay I will play
faster from now on okay all right Levy's
up 2-1 what did I play last time that's
right let me I forgot you you get a
dollar for that for that game yeah
really
that's two we tried to give away dollars
for people that recognize you but oh now
I think I think we would have lost all
of our money here if I win then do you
minus don't lose my hotel Key why don't
I thought you're gonna play faster
adjust oh man I really thought he was
gonna play H6 you could play G5
that's that's a sicilian after my own
heart oh my gosh
it's beautiful for black it's just
really cool Robert has look at this
position right here never go full Robert
Hess
who is going Robert hessenware just a
bad close Sicilian it's Robert Style
what is this guy
can me and Robert no no between you your
opinion on the close Sicilian
[Music]
there's a piece
if I just move back yeah that was part
of the plan because that was part of the
plan but he does get a whole lot of
Pawns a lot of checks do a little dance
again like you know playing Tawny like
if I was playing
who's a bad I am
if I was playing a bad I am I'd be like
oh he hung Bishop B6 but I'm like oh
Tony sacrificing you know like when you
you know you play some ghosts
for three pieces bro
[Applause]
all right yeah now I gotta now I gotta
hit him with all the moves him with all
the moves do I stack the Knight too
somehow yeah you're probably not right
no no Queen F3 really
[Music]
Ting D1 okay
okay isn't this just like over
[Music]
your position wasn't great and are over
the board game and you defended I mean
just look at this position I I'm looking
at it so lucky you don't have Bishop G5
so lucky I thought you were gonna say
you're so lucky I don't have like brain
cells or something I was like that would
have been a pretty good bit of trash
talk
[Music]
position I'm gonna cry it's so bad no
don't cry that's not gonna be that's not
fun nobody's having fun if that happens
um oh man like adults cry
this position is so bad
it's terrible
ah okay fine I'm gonna win one game at
least this game I mean that first game
you literally just sat down and
destroyed me so let me have three I have
one and now I'm gonna make it 43. yes
it's basically like I'm the Golden State
Warriors and he's he's the Cavs
oh but it was a very flashy one I think
this would work too
um now what openings do I know I guess I
gotta I gotta play my when I know best
right if I lose I don't know this
opening well though
it's only if I
wow this is exotic
you can only play like what is he gonna
play here
just a fancy move order this is the game
that messes up the database
I know yeah they're gonna be like
damn okay
hopefully wait a second isn't this like
if you go over here before we go D4 it's
normal yeah this is like not that bad
I'm gonna go Knight G3 and H4 and it's a
delayed yeah it's a delay the D4 this is
what I call it
Nigel short has played this against me
he's like Nitro short yeah you probably
also have I think this is
oh it's completely fine I'm gonna make
sure I can help you pictures are twenty
dollars
[Music]
look mad you know I'm gonna be focused
how do I compete against the crab like I
don't know
my man is hitting me with the crab okay
is it better is it better or worse to to
make you go here like if I go here
better for you or me
better for me better for you huh amazing
maybe maybe yeah
Uncle I'm wondering why I played this
right now yeah me too I'm just wondering
I don't like don't you have like good
prep like good coaching like I could
have just played my normal stuff yeah I
have to transit to this it's okay
actually wait a second look at this
isn't this beautiful it's all right
it's not like
what's so good about this we'll see more
playable than anticipated yeah exactly
unless oops but okay I just I like to
not Castle so this is just basically
activated like my secret power I can
travel right wait look at this position
actually I know I'm your opponent I kind
of have to unfortunately
unfortunately
I think it's better what do you think is
better
yes yes yes
that's offensive man I don't know you
gotta okay
um
Santa is equal sets I don't know I don't
know what's going on in this game right
I mean look at the queen side
over my pieces
um
[Music]
okay here we go inspired by me let's go
so now I have do I take a den go there
do I take first I think I think I don't
know I think you gotta do you man just
do you you've only got 30 seconds to do
you tell them it's time I mean I'm just
helping him
so I have an idea he was more than
capable of doing it himself
okay here we go
is going on
really okay
I feel like what happens if it's a draw
do we just replay I think wait a second
yeah
okay my hit right
it's been just overruled
the clock wait okay wait okay oh my God
it's the next time
what there it is that's a cool move
oh wow
thank you for the pawn okay but it's oh
my God
too many
uh-oh
no it was not there's a lot of things
going on here that are questionable
uh-oh wait a second oh wait a second oh
my goodness what
oh more
I don't know what's going on here
I made a call back I did it I feel like
what was the verdict of that I feel like
I won in my soul I think yeah all right
let me take some break and what you won
Levy won man
that was a lot going on I don't know my
opponent was uh doing a lot there